hey youtubers is Charlie so we just
found out what like 99% of the cast of
Captain American Civil War it's gonna be
so there's gonna be a breakdown and an
early preview some of the new characters
so just to talk about the new characters
first Martin Freeman is probably going
to be playing Everett Ross his character
is also going to be part of the Black
Panther film and Everett Ross is like a
Black Panther character he's someone
that works for the government so he
works well in both universes especially
considering all the politics that are
gonna be going on in Captain America's
Civil War the character is kind of like
a government liaison but you can see how
casting Martin Freeman they want a
little bit of drama comedy Marvel films
in general tend to be a little bit
lighter you know then say like the DC
films which are really super dark and
gritty so if you're wondering what they
might be going for just because Martin
Freeman has done some really ridiculous
comedy liked the office the British
version of The Office I'm expecting a
performance closer to the type of comedy
you would see in an episode of Sherlock
really gripping drama with comedy in it
the Everett Ross character in the comic
books kind of lends himself to that just
imagine a Watson type character reacting
to crazy superheroes they're bringing
back William Hurt as general fattiest
Ross from Incredible Hulk
that's a deep cut it also lends a little
more credence to the Everett Ross
character that was one of the biggest
casting surprises just because we
haven't seen him in so long you can see
how his character is perfect for civil
war there will be no question as to
which side he's going to fall on they
haven't officially confirmed Daniel
Bruhl scare achter but he is dollars to
doughnuts Baron Helmut Zemo just like
Martin Freeman is supposed to also
appear in Black Panther there's a rumor
that Daniel Bruhl is also going to
appear in Doctor Strange that should
speculation right now but you can see
how Hydra would still be a thing in the
era of civil war you know next year and
in the timeline it's really only going
to be like a year after this it's not
like it's gonna pick up years and years
after age of Ultron more heads of Hydra
rising up Baron Zemo just like one of
the biggest Marvel comic book characters
they haven't done yet there's also loose
ties to mysticism which you know could
be the end for Doctor Strange moving
further down the list another really big
surprise Paul Rudd's ant-man is going to
be in the movie just because Hawkeye is
gonna be in the movie - what I really
want to see is him stick ant-man on the
end of one of his arrows and fire at him
and do like the arrow punch just like in
the cartoons they'd be so hilarious
creative use of ant-man remember in the
trailer
hope Van Dyne said you're like a bullet
so why wouldn't Hawkeye fire him on one
of his arrows and then essentially the
entire roster of the New Avengers so you
have the vision Scarlet Witch
Black Widow Falcon and war machine and
for those that are asking yes Bucky is
in the movie Winter Soldier is coming
back he's so important to the Captain
America character there's no way he'd
ride the bench there was a small Falcon
Easter egg during Avengers age of Ultron
where they were like hey where you been
and he's like I've been on a missing
persons case they just means in the time
between Winter Soldier and age of Ultron
he'd been tracking down Winter Soldier
or trying to there's a lot of rumors the
cap might die and Bucky might take up
the shield there's a number of
characters like in the comics right now
Captain America is the Falcon but if you
go further back in the comics then
Winter Soldier became Captain America at
certain points so there are a number of
candidates I think they would go with
the Bucky character it'd be something of
a redemption for his character frank
grillo is coming back as crossbones
remember at the end of Winter Soldier he
got his face completely messed up so
he'll look a lot more like his comic
book character he and Chris Evans were
actually exchanging mean tweets with
each other I mean they were joking but
Frank Ritter was just basically telling
Chris Evans he's gonna beat the crap out
of him Emily VanCamp agent 13 is coming
back to her show on ABC just got
canceled she was on revenge there's a
lot of theories that she might do
another Marvel TV show but for now she's
gonna be in this Marvel film they're
gonna be filming for a long time - how
serendipitous you know I'm sure she
would have been in the movie anyway even
if her show didn't get cancelled but now
I think they could just make her part a
little bit bigger I think part of the
disappointment with her character in
Winter Soldier is that she almost wasn't
there she probably had more scenes that
just got cut out but now they can
feature her a little bit more because
she's a really interesting part of the
Captain America comics and of course
Black Panther is gonna be making his
debut in the movie and when I say debut
he's going to be in his vibranium
costume I've already done a couple
videos for the Black Panther movie so I
had a link in the description but
essentially you know his costume isn't
just a normal suit it's made of
vibranium weave doesn't it just remind
you of that Ultron joke in the movie the
most versatile substance on earth and
the humans use it to make up Frisby that
was one of my favorite quotes from the
movie we do not see ulysses klaw on the
cast list Andy Serkis isn't supposed to
be in the movie
it me as far as we know I totally don't
have a problem with that just because we
already have like half the cast of age
of Ultron coming to this next movie
Civil War is basically like Avengers 2.5
you have so many Avengers in it you
might as well call it that for those
that are wondering about the presence of
Iron Man in the movie you know I mean
it's a Captain America movie but you
have a lot of a list Avengers especially
Robert Downey jr. yes he's gonna be on
screen lot but is still gonna focus on
Captain America's character Robert
Downey jr. made this big deal after he
re-upped his Marlo contract about
stepping down his presence in the movies
but still appearing he still wants to be
Tony Stark he's still gonna be that
character but he just he's not gonna be
headlining as many movies as he didn't
phase one and phase two that's why you
don't see a solo Iron Man film on the
books in Phase three him unofficially
retiring from the Avengers at age of
ultron is kind of the transition Aquis
slowly stepping his presence down but
but it's not like he's quitting the
Marvel Universe he's not pulling a Hulk
and going off the grid for those that
are wondering where the hook is to he's
just wandering around he's just trying
to be away from people he'll totally be
back for Infinity Ward don't worry about
that any of the Avengers that you don't
see in Captain America Civil War will be
back for infinity war at least part two
if not part one there's a lot of
theories that you know anybody that dies
in Captain America Civil War might not
come back right away in Avengers
infinity War part 1 they've just started
to write that movie and they've already
said that part 1 in part 2 aren't going
to be like one film split in half
they're gonna be two distinct storylines
there's a number of things that could
mean but you know it's not like Secret
Wars where it's like this big giant
event series just split into parts
here's my big question for you guys you
know who are you most excited to see in
Captain America Civil War right now I'm
you know most excited to see more from
Scarlet Witch in the vision they have
such unique powers that we haven't seen
in the Marvel Universe yet that I feel
like it's gonna be so much fun just
seeing what they do and yes I totally
think that they're gonna push that ship
they're gonna have a relationship
it'll be a big falling-out that you know
they'll weave in a lot of the classic
comics vision and Scarlet Witch were
always a big thing you know but across
the comics you know they broke up they
had phantom babies that turn out to be
Mephisto I just I can't wait to see how
ridiculous they get with it ask for
characters dying though I know
everyone's asking about Quicksilver and
age of Ultron you know if you know
Captain America ends up dying that's an
even bigger deal the time gem is
really the workaround to that once you
have the gauntlet you can change
anything you want so they could hold the
time gem to infinity War part 1 and that
could be the way to bring back any dead
big franchise characters really I think
Thor 3 is gonna be our next gem based
you know huge WTF space movie guardians
of the galaxy is gonna be pretty crazy
too so you know I think they'll try to
integrate some of that but the most gem
related stuff I'm expecting out of that
movie it's just Stannis himself talking
about the gems you can only use gems as
the MacGuffin in big Marvel films a
certain number of times you can't do it
in every single film has it right now we
still need the soul gem still need the
time gem it would be fun to see the soul
gem show up in Doctor Strange and have
it be like his eye of agamotto but they
could go any direction they want to with
it also along those lines note that
Benedict Cumberbatch is not on the cast
list for Civil War part of that is just
because the actor isn't available I'm
sure I'm sure if he had the time he
would totally cameo and speaking of
which you know post-credits scenes a lot
of that's done during reshoots like
months and months after they wrapped
principal photography so we could still
see them setting up Carol Danvers
Captain Marvel Doctor Strange you know a
number of big characters that we just
haven't met yet they also have to start
weaving in powered people you know
Inhumans to the movie so I'll be
interested to see how they do that
because we don't have any big Inhumans
characters cast yet right now I see the
priority in terms of new characters is
weaving Black Panther into the mythos
gotta get some more vibranium speaking
of which I know a lot of people are
wondering about Iron Man's new suit he
had a new suit at the end of age of
Ultron that they totally did not mention
it looks a lot like the bleeding-edge
armor from invincible Iron Man number 25
that's actually kind of a riff on the
Iron Man armor from the first film just
you know with vastly upgraded parts they
didn't really address it in the film in
terms of them getting more vibranium
just because the vision was all the
vibranium that Ultron took I do think at
some point he's going to make a new suit
out of vibranium it would be stupid for
him to not so I think it depends on what
the relationship with Wakanda is gonna
be at the end of Civil War spider-man is
a big question mark we know he's gonna
be in the film in some way but they're
still finalizing the contract on the
actor it's it's down to like the final
list of candidates there's a sub
Butterfield Tom Holland Timothy sha'lame
I feel like any of those choices will be
fine the rumors are
now for like the Sony spider-man solo
films the ones they're making with
Marvel are gonna be him in sophomore
junior and senior year of high school
you know to be like a new trilogy that
means that he might be a freshman in
Captain America Civil War just so they
can integrate those Sony films into the
Marvel MCU timeline in a logical way
Kevin Feige did say that there is like a
teenage spider-man swinging around in
New York City right now you know in the
timeline that people just don't know
about the costume he has is gonna be way
more tuned down something way closer to
what a high schooler would come up with
I don't think that means it's gonna look
like cosplay but if Brian Michael Bendis
has his way he will have his mechanical
web-shooters so now that we know who
some of the characters are what I'm
probably gonna do is target some more
bonus videos on characters like do some
Scarlet Witch vision videos it's gonna
be a lot of fun so be sure to subscribe
to get everything if there's anything
you guys really want me to do just let
me know in the comments I've also got
some a man videos that I'm working out
too just because that movie is like a
couple months away so while you guys
wait for that stuff you can click here
for my Black Panther video and you can
click here to learn about all the big
cuts they made from age of Ultron thank
you so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight
you